foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] em
[Music]
yesterday I had to go on a rant about
Bob Iger the CEO of Disney
morning I have to laugh at the right
wing not these on Twitter
absolutely freaking out and melting down
and losing their minds
over a cartoon remake I'm not kidding
you it is all the buzz this morning all
the buzz I mean you would think you
would
you would think you would think they
made Snow White Snow black this morning
they are freaking the [__] out over the
pictures that have been released
of the Disney Movie remake reboot the
live action Snow White first of all they
are really upset that Snow White
is an actress who happens to be Latino I
don't I don't I can't figure this out I
I think I think they would be more upset
or less upset excuse me if snow might
snow white would have ended up being
blonde with blue eyes as opposed to have
dark hair with blue eyes hate you
[__] chuckleheads it's a cartoon
remake Disney it doesn't even adhere to
the original story of Snow White you
buffoons
Jesus Christ the actual Snow White that
you're talking about that is being
rebooted was a [__] remake of the
original story you dumbass
the other thing they're they're really
upset about oh they're [__] pissed is
that all the dwarves don't look like the
dwarves in the cartoon they just don't
look like them in in the cartoon
I
I don't know what I mean I mean they get
mad that they think Bud Light is gay
they think that the green M M's aren't
sexy anymore
they can't focus on anything but
genitalia they think rainbows and Target
are the end of the world
they were absolutely infuriated
when the little mermaid a mermaid a
mermaid a mermaid was black
I'm not [__] you this is part for
the course for these boneheads this is
their platform folks this is their
platform all the while Republicans
almost refuse refuse to fund the
military because d-e-i
affirmative action
Eli crane who made it on her bonehead of
the week pole uses the words colored
people on the house floor
and they have those words stricken from
the record he tried to amend them but
they struck them from the record
while while Tommy tuberville over in the
Senate defends white nationalist
what other what other [__] racism do
we have in the Republican Party
look if you're if you're not figuring
out what their platform is for the
general election next year you are not
paying attention
and let me tell you something as they
pick out this platform I couldn't be
more happy
of the stupid bigotry that they plan on
running
it's gonna be fantastic folks I'm
telling you all we have to do is engage
and we will stop the ever loving [__]
out of them I would guess if we can get
Democratic candidates in these State
seats the state representative state
senator races Democrats someone who's a
serious person worried about serious
government for people serious about
their lives if we can find those people
I bet we can turn some of these red ruby
red Republican Nazi super majorities in
these states
we may not be able to turn them to
Democrats but we may be able to get rid
of their [__] super majorities
all the while Iowa bans Women's Health
Care this is real stuff I don't know if
you know that
Iowa bans Women's Health Care that's a
real thing not not oh my God there's
someone who I don't like their skin
color playing Snow White
speaking of movies
yesterday
um I went over the Bob hiker interview
uh that [__] vile piece of trash
[__] on his workers and workers all
around the country you're not good
enough you just don't you just don't
understand how tough it is making 27
million dollars being a CEO peasant
and it's basically what he said
listen to me when I say this
that
they better get off their [__] stupid
high horse
the actors at sag
[__] you we're joining the writers we're
striking you can kiss our ass and
yesterday you know a lot of people are
gonna be like oh well all those actors
make all kinds of money folks that is
not that is not true there is a handful
of those performers in Hollywood that
make gobs and gobs of money
and have the ability to negotiate
contracts most of those actors in those
television shows in the movies and such
are are just lowly paid entertainers
just like the writers barely making it
most of them having two and three jobs
just to be one of those actors
so don't get it twisted but I do find it
kind of funny that we're
looping back around oh my God these
right Wingers never fail to give you a
good chuckle right
they never [__] fail
dirt I mean you should go to the snow
white thread on Twitter of course the
Nazi website is out in full force this
morning right they're like oh there's
black people as Dwarfs
Eli crane would use a different phrase
oh man
it is 2023.
and I know it feels like you're like God
damn how did we get here where the
Republican party is so [__] bigoted
how did we get here
well we've always been here folks
you you understand that right
that the Republican party has always
been bigoted
it always has been
it just didn't have the the [__]
racist clowns running the show right
they had some
some sense of not saying the quiet part
out loud
and then when Barack Obama became
president in 2008
it really it really started to turn
to where the the quiet part out loud was
gonna win them [__]
was gonna win them races
and a lot of these [__] chuckle heads
caught on to that they knew it was going
to make them a ton of money
they knew hatred would make them a ton
of money
in their hate grift
so they continued and continued and
continued while Barack Obama was
President and then it birthed Donald
Trump
much to our Chagrin here in this country
and because we didn't engage in our
democracy like we should have years
before 2016 because get it straight we
didn't lose
our grip on reality in 2016.
long before that did we lose our grip on
reality
Americans were paying attention to a lot
of things the economy crashed I don't
know if you remember this in 2008
race under George W Bush when he was
still the president the economy just
[__] tanked I don't know if you
remember the Great Recession I'm old
enough to remember it
I was a young adult
at that point starting a new family it
was a [__] you know that's kind
of funny they're always like Millennials
had it so good oh my God Millennials are
so good listen [__]
we're the generation the first
generation to grow up post 911 okay
number one so don't give me the trash of
we don't know tragedy in this country
most of our generation most of our
generation were the ones volunteering
for your 20-year War some of them were
little kids when 9 11 happened and they
went to war for you
then in 2008 we had a we had a Great
Recession as we were coming of age and
starting families and going to college
and supposed to you know start your life
oh yeah the Great American Dream
so don't give us this [__] about how
Millennium Millennials Millennials got
401ks man
they got [__] kids in school they're
not Millennials aren't children anymore
it's our turn that's right I said it
and I know the audience uh loves the
generational talk
but I find it kind of funny when we're
talking about a snow white live-action
remake for Disney after we've had
yes piles of remakes from Disney
piles of them
where the characters have changed the
voices have changed they've changed the
script they've changed how it looked and
oh my God I can't you remember
okay
you remember Aladdin remember that
Will Smith I don't know if you guys know
this he's a black dude
I don't know if you know that but Will
Smith played the genie in in
Robin Williams did the voice of the
original Genie now the genie is blue
right so I don't know what Eli crane
representative Eli crane would call a
blue genie I could only guess
Will Smith remember he played the genie
in the Aladdin remake he's a black dude
he replaced Robin Williams Oh my God
what a controversy
I don't I don't hear them yelling and
screaming about that
no
they don't
they don't scream and yell about that
it's because it is the time that it is
their outrage has to fuel their base and
their base are a shitload of incel white
Nazis fragile white men I'm gonna show
you the clip from from Charlie Kirk and
freaking out over affirmative action
right I don't have a clip yet of him
um at least I don't think so have him uh
yelling and screaming about snowflake
white that's what I called him did you
see that on the thumbnail snowflake
White
maybe they should have cast Charlie in
the parody
snowflake white I don't know maybe it's
a good video to make [__] I don't know
but I'm going to show you a clip of
Charlie Kirk and talking about
affirmative action and how a few a few
people that he he he likes to bash who
who
benefited from affirmative action would
have never never took the place of white
people listen you stupid idiots
affirmative action is not intended for
people of color
are minorities to take the place of
white people it is to intentionally seek
out and find those people of color
and the minorities who have the
credentials that are better than the
[__] white people who would inherit
it in the first place because they're
white you stupid [__]
affirmative action is is not to put it's
not to play Checkers and [__]
race race musical chairs
it's for it's intent
is to find the biggest and brightest no
matter where they're from no matter
their economic status no matter their
race no matter their religion find the
best and the brightest to be in your
school not just some white dude who's
daddy and grandpappy went to Harvard you
[__] dummies
and to denigrate people
who who arrived at Elite universities
who deserved much more than probably 30
or 40 percent of the people who were on
[__] Legacy scholarships
and Legacy
[__] admissions
at these schools way better test scores
much smarter much brighter
much more advanced for our feature in
our country
and to think that just be just because
the college
went and sought them out because they're
the best and the brightest
they searched the country
that that that that oh you're you're
oppressing white people who have the
privilege of going to college because
they got money or their daddy went there
the [__] out of here with this nonsense
that's why I was so pissed off about the
decision of uh taking affirmative action
out of college admissions
because it does Deliver us the best and
the brightest in our country not no
matter no matter their economic status
or their skin color you [__] idiot
that's that's the point of it
not to replace someone's rich white spot
but to get the biggest and the brightest
to be the best educated to advance our
[__] democracy to advance our power
our world power I thought you were
[__] Patriots
I thought you loved this country
wouldn't you want it to be the biggest
the best and the brightest no you want
it to be the whitest you [__] bigots
that's how I feel about the people on
Twitter yelling and screaming about Snow
White is a Latino and look there's black
dwarves I'm dead serious they're saying
this [__]
I'll show it to you if I put it on
threads
so here's what I've been doing I I I'm
trying I'm trying to get because it's
kind of weird
see like threads and Twitter when it
first started right it was it's kind of
similar right like the the feeling is
kind of similar but the more threads has
been picking up the more Twitter just
feels like a [__] Nazi dumpster fire
I just I mean just a huge
Nazi dumpster fire
over on Twitter and it's getting worse
and worse every single minute
every single minute it's getting worse
and worse over there
so I I took some screenshots this
morning to put them over on threads to
show the people on threads because I
don't think they're going back on
Twitter to be quite honest they're going
so I posted some screenshots of this
snow white [__] over on threads
and if you don't have a threads account
get a threads account and honestly right
now and they were moderators reminded me
yesterday because I'm not very good at
this YouTube thing I'm not very I just
like the rant and yell and scream right
about these [__] right Wingers I
don't do enough self-promotion here on
the show and I should do more
self-promotion I should I don't want to
bore you with you know give me money
help me keep this show going I don't
want to bore you too much with that I
want to give you content that you're
willing to support but here it goes
here's my shot at it
if you're on YouTube right now hit the
like button always hit the like button
remember when you come here the first
thing you should do is hit the like
button on YouTube rather you're on our
Channel or the up wires Channel and make
sure that you're subscribed
to the YouTube channel here at the Tony
Michaels podcast every single weekday
it's free free free 99 to watch it on
YouTube
doesn't cost you a single nickel I don't
make a single nickel off YouTube either
I hate my guts they ate my [__] I'm
surprised they still let me broadcast to
be quite honest sometimes they don't
sometimes they suspend me for [__] I say
or some some [__] troll gets offended
and they report it and then they pull me
down
but you know I'm I'm usually me and the
moderators are pretty nice to the trolls
right as long as they don't get out of
hand we we invite the hate here if you
love to hate me come on come on come
hate watch fine with me I'm I'm good
with it helps my algorithm you're
helping me out it sounds good to me
so you know usually the trolls don't get
too reporty you know what I mean and
they're probably going to report this
now that I've said that but go ahead and
like every single episode every single
episode that you come into live chat
like that damn thing
if you're over on if you're over on
Twitch do the same thing and I want to
tell you over on Twitch and we've had a
we we've had a great great run
at getting more and more followers over
on Twitch that that chat is Lively
we've had more people re-subscribe and
subscribe this morning
with their Amazon Prime account so on
Twitch there's some commercials every
once in a while
on Twitch if you want it to be
commercial free you have to subscribe
the free version has a few commercials
over there on Twitch I I let me see I'll
tell you how much I'm I made last month
I'll be transparent with it here's how
much I made last month on the um the the
commercials let's see ads
um
10.46 in the last period
so that actually
that shows you how lucrative it is
um
the show ads on Twitch to the viewers
but we got more and more viewers
happening over on Twitch but if you want
ad free you can use your Prime account
to get ad-free viewing on Twitch
you link your Amazon Prime account to
your Twitch account and I get a few
dollars of Amazon's money when you do
that just a couple bucks
out of the five dollars that they give I
only get a couple but you know again
every little bit counts all the support
counts and it's a great way for you to
to support the show with money for free
it doesn't cost you any extra if you're
an Amazon Prime member so go do that
also download every single episode on
Apple Spotify Google that helps us out a
lot even if you watch the show it helps
us if you download it because then we
get in the rankings it helps our
rankings on Apple and Spotify
so it it it gives us more generation of
more listeners
that's what it does also you can watch
it on Facebook if you want if you still
have a Facebook account at the Tony
Michaels follow us over there and if
you're on the up wires YouTube channel
go ahead and like that one as well the
upward.com is where you can find it or
you can just type in the up wire on
YouTube find that channel and you can
see the broadcast line from that channel
as well I got a great announcement this
morning you guys are gonna love this and
a few days ago I told you that Gabe
Sanchez was not gonna have the internet
power
to do
bonehead of the week today but we're
still going to do moan head he didn't
have the internet power to build all the
graphics but we have some graphics we
got him going Edward helped us out he
stepped in he's he's filling in for Gabe
to do some of the graphics so we got the
graphics going
we've got we've got I think we've got
everything we need to be to be bonehead
but I needed a guest co-host and you
guys gave a lot of suggestions for the
guest co-host and I have an announcement
to make if you haven't already seen it
Dr Rachel benicoffer is gonna come help
me do bonehead of the week at the top of
the hour how [__] exciting is that
how exciting is that Dr Rachel
bittickoffer is going to be here to help
me mock these sons of [__] in the
bone head of the week
that's great I'm excited you guys want
to have Rachel back and we got Rachel as
the guest co-host it's fantastic I can't
wait to have Rachel on today and do
bonehead we didn't do any prep work
either
I all I told Rachel was hey it's
bonehead of the week just follow my lead
so we'll see we'll see how we do with
the guest co-host we should do more
guest co-hosting I think
on days that Gabe can't make it we
should do more guest go host what do you
think I mean we got Texas Paul on
Tuesday anyways and and Gabe can always
come in and and and and join us but I
think we should do more guest co-hosting
I I like this I like this idea of
finding guest co-host I actually like
finding more guests the guest co-host
than guest the guest everyone always
wants a guest I we ain't got enough time
we need to get to three hours is what we
need to do we need to have more support
more viewers
and we can get the three hours I know we
can
uh some someone saying Richard ojetta
Thursday see that's one of the issues
too is like some of these other creators
you know they have their busy schedules
making their shows too so it's a tough
thing that's why Texas Paul joins us on
Tuesday
I mean it is it's Texas Paul Tuesday but
it just so happened that Tuesday was the
best day
for Texas poll
um so that's why we ended up on Tuesday
every Tuesday he joins the show
so it just that just happens like that
so we should do more guests co-hosting
um on days where Gabe isn't here
or where he can't join me as early you
know sometimes he's got a few things
going so he's late
but yeah I think we should do more of
that what do you guys think hell it's
Friday we might as well have a
conversation here someone's birthday is
in the chat whose birthday you guys are
saying happy birthday to somebody
whose birthday is it today I want to
tell them happy birthday live here on
the air someone someone gave me an idea
whose birthday it is uh did the
moderators know whose birthday it is did
it everyone's saying happy birthday
happy birthday happy birthday I want to
say happy birthday to him so if you know
whose birthday it is in the chat and put
it down there and I'll uh I'll get you a
happy birthday here on the um on your
crystal is it crystals but Roy Roy's
birthday oh it's Roy's birthday
okay happy birthday Roy happy birthday
Roy
it's a great day to have a birthday it's
Friday
July 14th here on the Tony Michaels
podcast uh someone asked what is Gabe
doing
he's he's camping he he went on a
camping trip
in an undisclosed location the problem
is is he doesn't have
internet there where he's well he does
just not good enough like he's got just
enough to connect to the outside world
he just doesn't have the internet to and
he needs he needs some time off we all
need time off we all need time away
especially time away uh from oh it is
Crystal's birthday too looks like it's
Crystal's birthday and Roy's birthday so
everyone wish Roy and Crystal a happy
birthday
in the chat happy birthday to the both
of you all right from me to you I'm so
glad to have you guys here on your
birthday that's exciting
that's exciting but that I gave needs
some time off we all we all need time
off we all need reprieve right and and
I'll be taking more time off from the
show we'll have uh Gabe host or some
guest host or something like that
um as we round out the summer now in the
fall I'm sure I won't be taking many
days off but there might be a few here
and there but we're gonna we're gonna
stay with you every single weekday as we
do as we do uh oh Rocket rod says don't
forget me from yesterday Tony it must
have been his birthday yesterday happy
birthday happy late birthday rocket rod
so happy birthday to anyone out there
who's had a birthday this week maybe we
should do like a birthday thing every
week if it's been your birthday I don't
know what do you think about that
the moderators are always coming up with
great ideas that sounds like a good one
to me
Cynthia says so Gabe is camping or
glamping I you know I'm not really sure
Cynthia if he's camping or going but
we'll have to ask him next week when he
gets back on the show rather it was
camping actual camping or clamping it's
been a long time since I camped when we
go we we glamp and technically
um you know
what what I mean what is the difference
between camping and glamping really I
mean I guess you know certain amenities
Maybe
oh all right I'm telling you it's going
to be a great show we got Dr Rachel
midikoffer at the top of the hour but
first but first I want to go show you
um what we've got with with Charlie Kirk
in the snowflake white don't go anywhere
we'll be right back right after this
you're going to want to watch this
commercial because
and the boy cat thing they're gonna
boycott this this Snow White for sure
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
trying to remember all the things you
boycotted can really get you stressed
because there's no good way to keep them
from becoming a cluttered mess well now
there's boycott binder the ingenious
organizer that keeps track of everything
and everyone you've ever boycotted the
72 category filing system makes it easy
to organize boycotted people places and
things so you can find them with ease
the large centered area can even fit
your boycott sign but best of all when
you're done the boycott binder folds
right up so you can take it anywhere so
if you're tired of having a cluttered
mess call now and get the boycott binder
for just 29.99 plus you'll also receive
our next rep as a bonus just Loop it
around your neck to travel with ease but
call right now and we'll double the
offer that's two boycott binders and two
neck straps for just 29.99 boycott
binders brought to you by the same
makers of binders full of women
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
oh they're gonna need it a lot of
boycott binders
you know here's the thing I don't know
if Disney is actually doing this on
purpose or if they're just getting
people who are like you know what let's
cast the right person in the role
[Music]
making it exactly like the cartoon
version that Disney ripped off from the
original story of Snow White because I
don't know if you knew that
there's like an original story of Snow
White you know and Disney did a version
of it so like technically the version
that they're [__] oh we we need to
get back to that Snow White that's a
ripped off version
Disney Walt Disney did this a lot he
would take he would take a lot of
stories and he would he would cartoon
them right he would animate them and he
would he would change the stories in a
way that would make them more appealing
to to children at the movies and
families now he did the same thing with
Mary Poppins Mary Poppins the the the
the the show that you see now there is
animation it's not an animated movie but
it's got animation in it actually Mary
Poppins I believe is one of the first
movies that has live action and
animation on the same one
um
and the original writer of Mary Poppins
did not want did not want animation in
the film and they did it anyways
um it's it it's part of the film what is
it called
um Saving Mr Banks I believe is what the
film is called with the where Tom Hanks
plays Disney now that's again that's
another fictional uh rendition of the
actual story of Walt Disney getting the
ability getting the rights to make the
movie Mary Poppins
it's it's so [__] ridiculous that
these idiots don't know this it's the
same it's the same thing as the beer
boycott you remember this dude [__]
they're still carrying on about Bud
Light being queer beer or some stupid
[__] I told you the story where I went
to a bar uh to an event it was like a
live music event I went in a bar to
order a beer I ordered a Bud Light some
guy behind me said oh did you order a
skirt with that beer and I turn around I
said what are you scared this beer is
going to make you gay
it really took him aback right he was
really confused when I took a big old
drink and I said now I want some dick
that's what I told him and I walked away
he was really confused
I think he really thought that the beer
makes you gay but this is the stupidity
that they have they didn't even know
that the reason why beer is regional
data had no clue why Bud Light was the
number one brand Across America they had
no clue they didn't know
because beer was Regional and the reason
why is because beer goes bad
they did and no you got to keep beer
cold
you gotta keep beer cold to keep it
fresh to keep it tasting the same as
what the [__] Brewery intended to
taste it's really it's not [__]
complicated stuff to know
and the reason why beer is so Regional
is because of that aspect
before refrigerators and Commercial
coolers it was really hard to keep beer
cold for a long distance so you couldn't
ship beer from [__] Georgia to
[__] Oregon okay it would be bad by
the time it got there so no one would
drink that [__]
okay got it yeah you understand now
that's why Bud Light was the first
national
beer brand and the reason why is because
Anheuser-Busch had the capability with
Bud Light to keep Bud Light the same
rather you ordered a Bud Light in
Georgia or you ordered one in Oregon it
tastes the [__] same
that's why Bud Light became the first
biggest National brand it was really the
national brand for a long time
brand of beer not company but light is
not a [__] company it's just a can
and it's just a certain Brewing process
to make it taste a certain way
and and the taste of Americans became a
very light beer unlike Europe where they
won a very heavy darker beer
Americans enjoy their watered-down beer
that's what they did that's that was the
market and that was the ability of
Anheuser-Busch to produce Bud Light
because of how light of a beer it was
they could get it to taste the same no
matter where they brewed it
you [__] idiots Jesus Christ how how
the [__] can't they know this
I I actually had to go on a Twitter
space and educate these boneheads when
this first started they were like oh
this is gonna destroy Anheuser-Busch I'm
like you people are dumb as dog [__]
number one Anheuser-Busch used to be an
American company it used to be an
American brand but in Bev bought it a
foreign company remember that it was
years ago people were [__] outraged
and upset about it and Anheuser-Busch
would sell their company to a foreign
brand
but they own Brands underneath the
umbrella of Anheuser-Busch
and one of the brands that's a top
selling brand in America right now
Modelo is an old Anheuser-Busch brand in
this country but they still own the
brand outside the country
it's really [__] dumb they don't
understand how any of this works that's
why they get confused
that's why they get confused the same
way about Snow White and Disney and
movies and how all this [__] Works they
get confused
that's why people like Michael Knowles
and Ben Shapiro and all these others are
failed screenwriters and they're failed
in Hollywood that's why they continue to
attack Hollywood is because they [__]
got their asses kicked there
because it sucks to suck
but they don't quite understand how
stories work it seems
Snow White the [__] Disney cartoon is
not the original version you boneheads
it's a book
you [__] idiots go look it up well
Don I don't want to get too [__]
crazy with them
[Laughter]
oh you [__] idiots again Mary Poppins
is another good example and the reason
why Mary Poppins is a good example of
this because Walt Disney
if you don't know Walt Disney worked his
ass off to get the rights to that story
to make that movie
he wanted that story and the reason why
is because his daughters love the book
but the original story behind Mary
Poppins is not this not the exact one
you see on the screen they they changed
it
boy it's almost like the original book
wasn't quite marketable that they
couldn't fit it in the 90 minutes that
they wanted they couldn't sell it with
the songs and the singing and the
dancing
which which the original writer did not
want the songs in the dancing in there
it's not complicated to know this stuff
you just gotta
just gotta use your [__] head
but that is the challenge with the right
Wingers especially the right wing on
Twitter right now is they don't use
their [__] head
and you might say Tony why again why is
it so important that you're focusing on
these boneheads going after Snow White
because this the listen they're going to
lose these things they're going to lose
these battles they lost the battle on
[__] Little Mermaid you remember that
they [__] freaking out about Little
Mermaid before you get out about it
oh my God I'm a black woman is playing a
mermaid
there's no black mermaids or some [__] I
don't know what they were thinking
mermaids are fictional characters they
don't exist
mermaids don't exist
there's another story
that was turned into a Disney cartoon
The Little Mermaid cartoon that they
made
was was a ripoff of the original story
Jesus Christ how don't they know this oh
yeah Aladdin same thing
same same [__]
same [__]
how don't they know this
Brenda says I'm doing my Nixon in person
personally more is that my Knicks in him
I didn't know even though that was my
Nixon impersonation it might be
it might be
all right
oh Dustin oh Dustin's here hey Dustin
Little Mermaid tanked you're a dumb Buck
you're an idiot go look at the worldwide
numbers you [__] you [__] chud
go look at the numbers dummy see what
you can't do Dustin is believe what
you're reading on Facebook because what
you're reading on Facebook from your
vile little you're by a little in-cell
army is wrong it's wrong dummy and Snow
White won't tank either you stupid [__]
it's not gonna tank you know the reason
why it won't tank Dustin
and here's what you don't know here's
what you don't know is you're in the
minority
you're the one who [__] you're the
one who's a bigot and he won't go see it
because she ain't Shane is wide as I
want her to be
and and them drawers aren't as short as
I want them to be where's their beards
at
you're a dumb [__] man
you're a dumb [__]
and I'm telling you Snow White's gonna
do just fine just fine just fine
now we may not get movies for a while
because the actors and the writers
deserve pay for works like Little
Mermaid and Snow White so I went and
watched Little Mermaid oh man it really
pissed Dustin off whoo boy I actually
posted I gave I went intentionally to
give Disney my ticket money
but at the credits the credits on Little
Mermaid Jesus Christ you should see how
many people worked on that movie God
damn there was a lot of people who
worked on that movie
that was heavy lifting and and again a
little mermaid wasn't actually one of my
favorite Disney remakes
as far as the ones that I've seen so far
it wasn't my favorite and I watched um I
think Mulan the Mulan one The Lion King
Aladdin
um what's some of the other ones that
they've done oh jungle book
um but The Little Mermaid was not really
one of my favorite Aladdin was okay I
really like Lion King
I like that one but it wasn't a live
action you know they're selling his
live-action I'm like um this is
animation
that is not live action
this is animation it's just not cartoon
animation
so I was I was kind of you know
it's kind of hard on Disney on that one
uh Dumbo I don't know that I've seen the
Dumbo one
uh beauty of the Beast one I've seen I
think yeah
so I mean again again this is so stupid
this is so stupid that they're freaking
out over one movie
and again you know it's not surprising
that Dustin's buying the talking points
you know he's a racist he's a bigot and
we we know Dustin we it's okay we got
your number and again Dustin I you
you're welcome to come here as long as
you don't say some stupid [__] [__]
then I'll block you but you know better
than to say really dumb [__] that way
you can stay here the other thing that
Dustin does I don't know if you guys
know this he invites all his little
incel friends to come watch
yeah he's got a hate hate Army that
comes in lunch so let me show you that
clip though I'm going to show you this
clip of Charlie Kirk because this is way
more important than the [__] snow
white [__]
um this is his little take on on
affirmative action uh Charlie Kirk is
talking about Joy Reed cantanji Brown
Jackson She's a Jackson Smith and
Michelle Obama of course you know he
can't help but talk about how white he
is and how oppressed he is because he's
a white man oh he's his little fragile
white male ego oh put Charlie Kirk Okay
let's listen to him whining [__] about
how about how really smart black women
are smarter than white dudes like his
dumbass you really have to wonder
in fact you know if if we would have
said
three weeks ago Blake if we would have
said that Joy Reed and Michelle Obama
and Sheila Jackson Lee and katange brown
Jackson were affirmative action picks we
would have been called racist yeah
because you are racist and the reason
why the reason why you would call them
affirmative action picks isn't because
they were actually affirmative action
picks you think it's a derogatory
statement just like you [__]
think trans is derogatory that's why it
offends you when you're called sis
because you think trans you use trans as
derogatory and it's not it's not
derogatory I don't know if you know that
so people who who benefited from
affirmative action it's not derogatory
to say that in fact
but when you're like oh you took our
White Spot you black person that's
racist when you're when you're using it
that way
listen I wanna I wanna give you guys a
clue here and I really want to tell uh
Charlie Kirk and Dustin I'm sure you
[__] listen to this piece of sludge
on The Daily him Shapiro [__] Michael
knows all those Nazis that's why you're
that's why you appear to be Nazi
adjacent because you're listening to a
bunch of [__] white supremacists
neo-nazis okay the America first real
America First Nazi party
let me give you a clue here let me tell
you something about this
and I's a white-skinned dude eyes a
white skin dude you can see I'm a
cracker if I ever was one popping out of
a Saltine box let me tell you something
do you know people who aren't afraid to
talk to you about affirmative action
they're not afraid to talk to you about
race in this country they're not afraid
to talk to you about bigotry they're not
afraid to for to talk to you about their
experience black people did you know
that they just they'll talk to you about
it they will if you'll [__] listen
if you open your [__] ears and listen
they'll talk to you about it it's not
it's not something that you have to hide
from it's not something that you have to
tiptoe around they they literally will
tell you their experience if you will
listen but Charlie Kirk doesn't listen
see that's the problem that's why he
thinks he thinks when he's talking about
affirmative action it's derogatory and
racist or whatever the [__] he says the
reason why is because he believes that
Joy read catanji Brown Jackson Sheila
Jackson Smith
Michelle Obama they all he believes they
all got their positions because they're
black not because they were qualified
listen
but now they're coming out and they're
saying it for us
by the way they've always I'm only here
because of affirmative action yeah we
know that's not what they said that's
how they do not have the brain
processing power to otherwise be taken
really seriously see there you go see
that that is where the derogatory part
of when Charlie's talking about
affirmative action okay
that's it right there right there
and a lot of white people that look like
me are scared to talk about this stuff
but you shouldn't be you shouldn't be
you shouldn't be scared to defend
to defend things like affirmative action
if you know why the [__] it's there and
you know how it's used in like I don't
know college admissions instead of
believing the [__] you read on Facebook
and the [__] [__] idiots like this
say about it continue Charlie with your
stupidity
you had to go steal a white person's
slot to go be taken somewhat seriously
play there it is there it is that's what
he thinks affirmative action is Charlie
is a really is a really uneducated
[__] do you remember why I've been
saying they say all this complicated
[__] to sound smart they want to make
the dumb feel smart like Dustin Dustin's
a dumb [__] he's a stupid [__]
he's a dumb Buck but he listens to
Charlie and he pukes up talking points
from Charlie and Trump and Shapiro and
[__] bongino and Tucker Carlson he
pukes him up and he feels smart hey Fayo
smart hey hey Tony did you know a little
mermaid did awful no it didn't dummy go
look at the worldwide numbers you
[__] idiot
do you know did you know that that
little mermaid didn't make no money
you think you sound smart you're dumb
and they're be you're being duped by
people like Charlie Kirk Dustin you're
being duped by them and all Dustin's
friends that are watching because I know
Dustin's friends are watching too
so when I say Dustin I mean all my God
and all people like Dustin launching all
you fragile white man man out there
and we can't go see a little mermaid
even though we won't watch it you don't
even like the cartoon the [__] out of
here
you [__] idiots okay let's let's
continue with
Charlie's
racism here at 52.
but I rise today as a clear recipient of
the first affirmative action I'm
particularly in higher education
I may have been admitted on affirmative
action both in terms of being a woman
and a woman of color
but I can declare that I did not
graduate on affirmative action this is
my personal story
I I hear because of action affirmative
she can't even say that
[Music]
we know
when he's saying we know when he's
saying we know he means us fragile white
men that's what he's saying
so that's his projection there us
fragile white men who did not have the
test scores to get into the schools
that katachi brown Jackson Joy Reed
Michelle Obama and Sheila Jackson Lee I
think I said Smither Sheila Jackson Lee
got into because of their test scores
and their qualifications we can't get
into we know we know we're a bunch of
dummies but we're white We're white and
we're men so we should get first chance
that's what Charlie's saying that's what
he means by we
it's very obvious to us that you are
smart enough to be able to get in on
your own because because you're black
say it Charlie say it with a heart
[__] [__] say it stop stop beating
around the bush you racist [__]
stop beating around the bush you [__]
Nazi I'm so sick and tired of them doing
this type of [__] these dong whistles
just say it already just say it just say
it with a hard Arc come on man stop stop
and stop playing like you're gonna say
it not gonna say you [__] puss
I couldn't make it on on my own so I
needed to make take opportunities from
someone there it is you know this is how
arrogant Joy Reid and katange brown
Jackson and Michelle Obama and Sheila
Jackson liar they're so narcissistic
they think this is persuasive
they think we're like oh of course
that's why we need affirm no no they
don't think you do man they don't think
you do
you know you're a dumb [__]
just like just like Dustin may come here
for years and years and years and still
Dustin and his band of incels come here
and [__] listen for years and still
not get since not talked into him okay
you people don't have a couple brain
cells to rub together so they don't
expect you to understand it not you you
Nazi yes Christ they don't think you're
gonna understand it affirmative action
because you have impressed us with your
brilliance
of course
oh no imagine the world without Joy you
know it's funny you know what's funny
about this this little thing he's doing
here because he's really bad at this
Charlie gerk is not a good broadcaster I
don't know if you know that did you did
you notice that did you notice he's not
a good broadcaster he doesn't he
he doesn't do his hand motions in the
same Rhythm as his voice he looks stupid
in the [__] tie and pretentious dude
you're standing you're in a microphone
it's a radio show man what do you need a
time for I mean you're ugly as [__] no
ties gonna make you look good Charlie
it's just not you look like a dumb [__]
and go get some surgery some gender
affirming surgery for that [__]
hairline and that [__] that small
face on your big ass head there's plenty
there's plenty of [__] available
surgeries out there to fix that [__] to
make you look more manly go lift some
weights a little bit too that might
[__] help I don't know you guys think
weight lifting and muscles look manly so
go do that man instead you look like a
little wimp but you know that's how
badly it is is it this he's horrible at
this he's [__] horrible at it
he's horrible at it but he says the most
vile crazy [__] and the reason why
Charlie Kirk is who he is is because
he's been able to fundraise from a bunch
of big money Nazis
did you know turning points USA oh man
that's why that's why Charlie Kirk is
who he is is because he's raised big
money
big money
from those [__] Rich Nazis out there
all right let's finish up I want to show
you if I can find it the joy read clip
I'm gonna show you this to show you what
Joy Reid says about affirmative action
and her affirmative action so we can
kind of get a sense of what Charlie's
[__] talking about read
imagine the world about Sheila Jackson
Lee or Michelle Obama or katanji brown
Jackson they think this is persuasive
they think as they kind of now reveal
that I'm only here because of anti-white
anti-asian force discrimination policies
that turned me into a bitter resentful
activist that hates white people
honestly
so now he's he's mad he's mad that Joy
Reid katangi Brown Jackson don't like
Nazis like him hmm listen this idea that
that they don't like white people you're
so [__] dumb you're dumb as dog [__]
this is the stupidest thing I've ever
heard in my life
they don't like bigots
they don't like bigots the problem is is
that with white supremacy it's
institutional in this country so a lot
of white people are bigots they're
[__] bigots and really honestly if
you are white in this country you start
at bigotry you got to work your way out
of it trust me I know
I was one at one point that's that's how
I grew up
I had to change my mind
I had to use my [__] brain cells and
come to some rational thought and reason
to figure out that oh okay that Equity
inequality that makes way more sense
and makes way more sense that'll Advance
our democracy way quicker way quicker
than the institution of white supremacy
and you know what if we just use white
privilege to tear that [__] to
the ground and Destroy privilege and
give everyone Equity inequality that
would probably make it even faster just
saying that's you know so yeah this idea
that oh man let me see if I can find
why is it not what the okay I'm gonna
see if I can find This Joy Reed clip
before
before Rachel bittick offer joins is she
going to be joining us here in about
five minutes and we're gonna do bonehead
of the week now bone of the week again
you're gonna have to bear with me
because bone of the week is going to um
is gonna go a little fast this week
because
uh we're doing it on we're doing it on
a shoestring here but we're gonna do it
we're gonna do it with Dr Rachel
bittickoffer so don't don't go anywhere
but I'm gonna see if I can find this
clip of Joy Reed telling you about
affirmative action here I believe she
did it on um
was a Chris Hayes show that she did this
I don't know I think that's where this
was
and she explains she explains like in
words intelligent words of you know how
affirmative action actually you know
it does work because they found her
they found her
here it is I believe this is it
yes here it is
and here it is here's Joy Reed listen
listen to her her actual side of the
story well let me just be clear I got
into Harvard only because of affirmative
action I went to a school no one had
ever heard of in Denver Colorado in a
small suburb I didn't go to Exeter or
Andover I didn't have college test prep
I just happened to be really nerdy and
smart and have really good grades the
good SAT scores but someone came to
Denver Colorado to look for me a Harvard
recruiter flew to Denver and I met up
with her at the Village Inn Restaurant
and did a pre-interview to get to route
to pull me into Harvard I wasn't I was
pulled in and the school's like
affirmative that I got into
affirmatively yes and it was literally
not saying we're going to take an
unqualified person and put them in
Harvard we're going to take a very
qualified person who we would never know
existed and put them in Harvard that's
how I got there that's how katanji got
there that's how well Justice Jackson I
should say justice Jackson got there
it's how Clarence Thomas got there right
but the minute I arrived for my majority
black little town Montbello in Denver to
Harvard the first like week or two that
I was in class my presence was
questioned by white people I was in this
big conference class where some white
students stood up and said those
students the black students they're only
here because of affirmative action it
became a huge argument that we all ended
up having this was freshman year I had
never had my academic credentials
questioned I had never had anyone
question whether I was intelligent until
I got to Harvard and it was a defining
uh point of my experience there it's why
I really was one of the many reasons I
was miserable there in my freshman year
yeah okay so that's a bit of Joy's story
about affirmative action
now again I want to tell you that black
people in this country are not scared to
talk about racism they're not talked
they're not scared to talk about
affirmative action they're not scared to
talk about bigotry they're not scared to
talk about how they're treated and their
experience
Joy did it on National Television there
the problem is the problem is
is a lot of people don't listen
right A lot of people don't use their
ears to listen
because you might you might hear the
first part of what Joyce said and say
well hey that makes a lot of sense they
they sought her out she had really good
test scores they wanted the good test
scores in Harvard
period and then you might stop listening
but her experience about it her
experience about affirmative action goes
much further than just Harvard finding
her because she's smart and she had
really good test scores
and her academic her academic record was
impeccable
they sought that out they went to find
Joy they went to find Joy Charlie
but if you stop there with with Joy's
experience of affirmative action you
would be derelict in your duty and that
is what we have to do in this country
because again
people of color are not scared to talk
about their experience especially their
experience with racism all you have to
do is listen you just have to listen to
him Charlie you just you just gotta
listen man
just listen to their experience not not
only take your own experiences
as as The Benchmark my friend my my
white friend Charlie Kirk do you know
what
foreign
ER actually debated Charlie Kirk so I I
think this is a good segue into the
bonehead of the week she did she she
debated him I don't know it's like a
year ago or so so she knows she knows a
thing or two about Charlie and his
feeble little fragile ways
he is he is quite quite the wimp
um and not to Rachel bittickoff for I
don't know if we'll have time to talk
about it for bonehead of the week
because I really got to get the bonehead
of the week but we got doc here it's
Friday we're in the second hour and you
know what that means in the second hour
the Tony Michaels podcast on Friday
bonehead of the week don't go anywhere
we'll be right back with our guest
co-host doing bone out of the week Dr
Rachel bittickoffer don't go anywhere
we'll be right back right after this
we'll be right
mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
I've always wanted to learn a new
language but whenever I try it never
sticks so when Babel made a MAG Edition
I knew I had to give it a try Babel Mega
Edition makes it really easy to learn
and there's lots of lessons to choose
from like subtly racist to full-blown
white supremacists the first lesson
began with learning simple phrases and
soon I was putting those words and
phrases into a conversation each lesson
takes about 10 to 15 minutes to complete
and they're all really different which
keeps things interesting the app is
really smart it actually keeps track of
the words that I'm struggling with I
chose Babel mag Edition because it's
created by smart white people like me
and now I can't wait to explore meet new
friends and use my new Mega skills with
my in-laws all lives matter
[Music]
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show you know what
time it is it's second hour D Tony
Michaels podcast Friday July 14th if a
guest co-host doing phone end of the
week
you know what bonehead is you vote you
decide who is the bonehead of the week
and me and my co-hosts today Dr Rachel
benicoffer break it down for you in
bonehead of the week I am so excited
well look at there we already got the
Moon Head Up
Dr Rachel bit a cover I'm so glad you
joined me for bonehead of the week I'm
excited to have you yeah I've never done
this before so okay so here's how let me
tell you let me tell you how bonehead
works let me tell you that way the
audience can get a sense of how it works
too if you're new listening out there in
the audience how bonehead works we put
up a poll every single Thursday on
Twitter hopefully one of these days
they'll get polls on threads so we can
get off the pull off Twitter but we put
a poll on Twitter and we put a poll on
YouTube and we have three contestants
each week for bonehead of the week and
the audience votes we're trying to get
them to to practice voting Rachel that's
what we're trying to get them to do is
to get in this democracy mode and really
get them practice voting so they vote
every single week who is the biggest
bonehead of the week I have to tell you
we have someone on the bonehead of the
week that is somewhat somewhat of a
juggernaut in the bonehead of the week
category I think she's only lost twice
um but we'll get we'll get to who the
winner is so here's what we do then we
break down who is the bonehead so once
the viewers vote we break down on why
these idiots why these Republican
nincompoops
sometimes not always Republicans but
most the time they are you know how that
goes these ninka boops are on the bone
of the week so let's break it down here
were the choices this week Dr Rachel
been to cover representative Eli crane
representative Marjorie Taylor green
there seems to be a pattern with the
House of Representatives I don't know if
you noticed that and then Disney's CEO
Bob Iger he really stepped in it this
week so we put and there could have been
more contestants I mean we had Tommy
tuberville uh out there saying crazy
white nationalist stuff uh we had Trump
Trump's always a great candidate in this
uh in this poll Lauren bobert I'm sure
said something crazy Matt Getz Steve
Bannon Mike Lindell lost his company's
auctioning stuff off there's a lot of
boneheads to pick from this week but we
thought uh with yesterday's news of Bob
Iger and Elon Crane and then we can
always count on Marge the petty Eddie to
be on bonehead of the week so let's
start here the first contestant I want
to start with is Eli crane Rachel
biddick offer so I'm going to show you a
clip yes yesterday that happened
on the floor of the house now it's been
a long time since someone's probably
said this on the floor of the house it's
probably been a long time since someone
said this
um but here is Eli crane on the floor of
the house see if you can catch how he
refers to to black people and people of
color Arizona well Mr chairman though
that was unbelievably inspiring
my amendment has nothing to do with
whether or not colored people or black
people or anybody can serve okay he
caught himself don't you think Rachel he
kind of he sure did
I'm gonna show I'm gonna show you the
inside boys
I'm well I'm gonna show I'm gonna show
um the rest of the clip because they
they try to strike it from the record
and then he's like oh I want to amend it
because he looks like good yeah let's
see it give me give me well give me your
first your first instinct of when he
says this I mean how long has it been
since someone has said this and referred
to to people of color black people on
the floor of the house as colored people
as Eli crane referred to him how long
has it been
yeah I mean I'm assuming one would have
to go back to the the 60s to the debates
over the Civil Rights and Voting Rights
Acts and 64 and 65. you know I think
I mean I don't know right I mean that's
my guess because it is a faux pas and
you could tell that he did it and
realized ooh I used my inside the
Republican Party voice right like I I'm
not supposed to say coloring people in
public only when I'm hanging out with my
Republican right white nationalist
friends Rachel Rachel you're white in
America right and you know when you're
in a restaurant with other white people
and you got that one friend who's gonna
tell that joke you know what I'm talking
about and he's like hey I want to tell a
joke but they look around the restaurant
to see if there's any person within
earshot that might get offended by this
joke so you're saying that's kind of
what Elon crane did here he didn't look
around the room yes he just said it out
loud right and that's I think that
actually is what they're doing more and
more is the quiet part out loud
well that's because the more that they
feel free within their own circles
because for a long time it was you know
frowned upon even in these deep red
districts to be overtly racist right
you're allowed to be implicitly a racist
you're allowed to dog whistle all you
wanted but to be obviously racist was
frowned upon because it was considered
to be that electoral politics for the
party's brand right so as those rules
have loosened in their own circles it's
got their tongues wagging and wagging in
a way that they don't always forget to
transition back when they're in public
and you could see it immediately he says
and and color people black people
as soon as it came out of his mouth his
brain went oh I can't say that I'm I'm
in Bad Company here again
right right right right right yeah
that's what happens when you take the
lid off of crazy [__] like that Tony is
exactly that you start you start to it
starts to bleed over into public even if
you try to hide it right well here's
here is
um where Democrats because Democrats are
usually on the floor of the house to
rebut a lot of this and the and as soon
as this comes up
um and I I believe it's uh lee
representative Lee that stands up and
says hey strike this from the record
immediately uh which Elon crane then
decides he's going to amend it and as
opposed to strike it because he doesn't
want to show that it's stricken from the
record he wants to show that he didn't
actually mean to say that which is not
what happened he meant to say that he
meant to say that and that's why they
want to strike it from the record but
you know what's funny before I move on
to that I'm looking at Eli crane here
does he give you the sense of being
Superior like just looking at him does
he really give this is he ooze
superiority like from I don't know this
weird does he have a turtleneck on he
didn't even have a tie on I don't know
what this is
um and then his hairdo yeah I'm not
feeling particularly inferior yeah it
doesn't it's not spiking my inferiority
complex it looks like a lot of the dudes
that went to grad school with well he
does look like that he does look like a
Judd because he is one but let's let's
listen to the Democrats here uh get this
get this officially stricken from the
record and it takes a bit but let's
listen to it it's worth the listen
because a lot of times I think Americans
stop at the process right they don't
know how the house Works they don't know
how the tick tock works of how bills get
through the house how this stuff works
how the debates on the floor work I
think sometimes that's what we lose in
the juice right because it's not always
sexy like the debates on the floor and
that sort of thing isn't sexy but watch
how they strike this from the record I
think this is uh I think this is
interesting here it has nothing to do
with Mr Speaker
any of that stuff what we want to what
we want to preserve and maintain is the
fact that our military does not become a
social experiment we want the best of
the best we want to have standards that
guide who who's in what unit what they
do and I'm going to tell you guys right
right now the Russians the Chinese the
Iranians the North Koreans they are not
they are not doing this because they
want the strongest military possible I
hope my colleagues on the other side can
understand what we're doing thank you so
much Mr spending to be recognized to
have the words colored people for what
purposes gently seek recognition I'd
like to be recognized to have the words
colored people stricken uh from the
record I find it offensive
and very inappropriate
um I I don't have the whole clip there
damn it but they go on because Eli tries
to Eli crane tries to get it amended as
opposed to stricken and they want it
stricken from the record is because they
want it shown as a strike not as an
amendment like he said something wrong
he said something wrong now to be fair
to Eli crane he was in the service but
you know you notice there the thing that
he does is he props up Putin's Army as
if there's some kind of picture-perfect
example of how you would want to have a
military it's [__] hilarious even as
Putin
about to what seems to be falter
progression possibly in Russia he's not
powerful he's not strong they're weak
they're weak because of of Eli Crane's
world view it's insanity
yes
exactly so yeah it's funny because you
know I wouldn't be pointing to the
Russians as a shiny example of military
superiority right now
well I wouldn't either but here is here
is the great speaker barely speaker as I
call him of the house Kevin McCarthy
here's his quick response to Eli Crane's
um
bigoted speech yesterday let's call it
what it is but he thinks it's something
else he's gonna take Eli at his word
is that acceptable that's not acceptable
I'll take him out his word that he
misspoke I have never heard him use that
before
I've never heard him say that before
when Kevin McCarthy says those words
into a microphone
doc I'm like I'm like you said it you
said it you said it come on yeah yeah
yeah
McCarthy has heard from really deeply
disturbing things dude
in fact you know he's got a caucus full
of white nationalists uh you want me to
tell you want to pretend he's never
heard them use the word colored people
before [__] dude
exactly exactly well as Tommy tuberville
let's let's speak about that for a
second because I don't have him on the
pole here but that's been an ongoing
thing this week with Tommy tuberville
because we could have put him on there
but he's kind of de facto with Eli crane
here uh in this this this Miss speaking
which he did not misspeak like you said
he spoke the way he speaks around white
people into a microphone when he
shouldn't have but the the thing is is
that Tommy tuberville has almost even
gone further this week uh within white
National and stuff yes what do you what
do you make about that tell us about
what you make of the the white
nationalists talk I mean to be clear
guys what tuberville has said is uh no I
don't like the racist not Nationalist
and the reporter you know was like do
you you understand what white
nationalism is and explain him you know
it it argues that the white race
Superior so like there literally is no
non-racist white nationalism and having
heard that explanation he you know just
disagrees or he likes the non-racist
white nationalists they're Americans
right they're not extremists or whatever
right and there hurts his voting block
so he he's really him in the Oklahoma
superintendent of schools for me would
have been definitely on the bonehead of
the week list here you are you're
perfectly allowed to teach Oklahoma
students about the Tulsa race riot as
long as you don't mention race okay well
explain the [__] ocean without using
the word wet
okay
teacher why did they go and destroy all
these people's houses and burn them and
Lynch them I would tell you but it's a
felony right
it's a felony for me to even speak the
truth the rights and Liberties dude Tony
I taught civil rights and Liberties for
years as a professor right and I sit
there and I try to imagine myself
explaining Southern segregation the Jim
Crow system the Civil Rights and Voting
Rights Act and not not making white
people feel bad about being white by
mentioning the fact that white people
disenfranchised and subjugated black
people and kept them living in separate
you know worlds basically under the
racist philosophy that white people are
superior to black people I mean how am I
supposed to teach like oh you know they
have this giant sit-in they're getting
beaten with clubs on the bridge in Selma
what's it about well the right to vote
well okay well why don't they have the
right to vote uh I tell you but it's a
felony right
um
so yeah anyway that's my personal
bonehead
Oklahoma Oklahoma where the truth is a
felony oh boy that's a good that's a
good good State model for Oklahoma where
the truth is a felony it is we should we
can get a bill there um
somehow somehow and uh voted on that's
their new state motto speaking of people
who don't give a [__] about the Common
Man Bob iger's really stepped in it this
week I think with this interview he had
a really good chance
um because you know he's talking about
um the the writer strike and the actor
strike we we saw uh some video of Fran
dresser yesterday
um dragging sag into this which they
should the actor should stand with the
writers the writers should stand with
the actors these people in Hollywood
should stand together because a lot of
people I think are like well all these
actors make all this money I'm like yeah
it's just a handful of them okay it's
just a handful of the actors that make a
lot of [__] money there's a lot of
actors out there that have second and
third jobs a lot of writers out there
that have second and third jobs that
work on these big projects and they just
don't get paid enough that's why they're
that's why they're trying to get paid
and Bob Iger really stepped in it um
because he didn't just step on the
actors and and the writers but he really
stepped on Common working people because
I and I talked about this yesterday with
the pandemic when we came out of the
pandemic there was there was this sense
that this uh that essential worker like
oh I wasn't a central before but I am
when you need me and then when the
pandemic's over you don't need me
anymore I'm not essential anymore right
and and America has and the working
class has gotten wise to this but let me
show you a little bit of Bob iger's uh
[__] stepping here and then we'll talk
about it on the other side
um speaking of content we're in the
midst of a like and very likely it would
seem to have a actor's strike how is
that going to impact things and what are
your expectations there
well I think it's very disturbing to me
I you know we've talked about uh
disruptive forces on this business and
all the challenges that we're facing and
the recovery from covid which is ongoing
it's not completely back this is the
worst time in the world to add to that
disruption uh I understand uh any any
labor organizations desire to work on
the behalf behalf of its members to get
you know the most compensation to be
compensated fairly based on the value
that they deliver we managed as an
industry to negotiate a very good deal
with the Director's Guild that reflects
the value that the directors contribute
to this great business we wanted to do
the same thing with the writers and we'd
like to do the same thing with the
actors there's a level of expectation
that they have that is just not
realistic
realistic for them to expect to be paid
a decent wage doc it just is unrealistic
to Bob Iger a guy who makes 27 million
dollars unprotected right yeah yeah I
mean you know you'd expect people to
just roll over and let like you know
their jobs be eliminated by Ai and you
know live off of breadcrumbs forever why
Bob people like Bob Iger are making 140
million dollars a year right so yeah you
know you know here's the thing as I
would tell Bob either the wrong time was
during the pandemic we're cutting off
people's entertainment literally would
have affected Public Health right people
needed the Escape of good entertainment
through that pandemic to survive now is
the right time because guess what the
labor economy is under a lot of supply
and demand pressure and this is the time
for any worker in any field to to
advance their own causes or you know
collectively through a union and fight
for better wages and compensation if not
now when right you surely don't do it
when unemployment is high and you can be
easily replaced that's not how [__]
works right a business guy like Bob Iger
you would inspect you know a ruthless
cut for a capitalist to understand that
so you know suck it up Bob
right right yeah pluck your head out of
your ass the other thing I think is the
biggest thing that Americans learn
through the pandemic because he brought
up covid right and this is what these
capitalists do when they're like look we
gotta raise prices so our profits are
high because covid was three years ago
you know what I mean but here's the
thing that that people learned during
coven
before covid before coven for the
essential worker thing happened before
the lockdowns and our economy had this
strain on it because of the virus
because millions of people were dying
from a virus a novel virus the thing
before that people people thought well I
should appreciate that I work for this
Corporation X right
and then and then they discovered oh you
know what I get it now I'm trading my
labor for their money we're trading here
so I'm trading my labor for your money
so you need me as much as I need you so
you should appreciate my labor right and
I think that's the process that happened
with the American worker and the
American working class because we lost
track of that because we lost track of
that because Republicans messaging a
narrative has always been on point for
lies right they've always been able to
sell these lines to the American public
that look the rich people are the job
creators and you should feel you should
feel appreciative that these
corporations are even giving you this
great job that you have that you can't
make a living off of you should be
appreciative of it and one day one day
if you work hard enough at those jobs
that you should appreciate that they're
giving you maybe one day you'll be rich
as us that's why we need to lower taxes
so that way one day when you're rich you
won't have taxes which will never happen
but that's always been that
uh that the Republicans have done a
really good job
right right yeah
so do you do you think do you think
going forward that this because you you
kind of spoke to that do you think that
we as as a collective with our narrative
because we talk about me and you talk
about this a lot do you think we can
build on changing that narrative and and
maybe this sag and the writer's uh
strike is a good way to show that
visually to the country
yeah because you know for I mean that is
the narrative and Tony that's excellent
encapsulation of what the Republican
economic message is right you can't text
us now because eventually you'll be one
of us and you don't want high taxes
right but you know where they started to
sell that frame and really elevate it in
the 80s 70s 80s 90s 2000s we're not in
1990 anymore I tell Democrats this all
the time now we have 50 years of
Reaganomics let's go prosecute the case
right trickle down and starve the Beast
have been an absolute abject failure for
the American middle class and it's a
really easy argument to make so in my
opinion they've kind of set them up that
that frame sets us up quite nicely to
tell these you know tell these folks
who've been voting for decades for
Republicans where's your [__] money
right you've been doing this for for
years and and what have you seen Rural
America you've seen absolutely the
opposite right the Republican Party have
ruled rural politics now on corrupted
for 30 years and what has Rural America
experienced degradation Decline and
fleeing children right so I do think
it's time you know you use these
assumptions and and
um you know understandings of the
broader less informed electorate about
what each party does for the economy it
it absolutely sets them up easily to be
prosecuted for the record which is again
abysmal
it is abysmal I I was watching a video
today by Tennessee holler uh it's a
local news report there where
Republicans are intentionally putting
strain on Rural hospitals and Rural
hospitals are dying with the intent of
Republicans because they won't expand
Medicaid and it's so they can blame the
ACA they can be like see Obamacare bad
see what happened and it's because they
didn't actually Implement Obamacare in
Tennessee is the reason why rural
hospitals are suffering it's not because
of Obamacare it's because they won't
implement it in Tennessee I mean it's
2023. it's been a couple months since
Obamacare was enacted it's been a couple
months since Medicaid expansion was
available to Tennessee but they won't
take it right and it's an example we
don't have to defend hypotheticals
anymore we have real tangible data and
you know I think the Newsome team picks
this up to pick this bowl up and run
with it really well because if you hear
his messaging as of right of late what
he's doing is he's making what I've been
arguing for years we need to do a blue
State versus Red State argument right
here here are the states Democrats
control there's less uninsured people
hired uh life expectancy lower infant
mortality better GDP better retire
whatever right all these metrics that
you know other than low income tax we
win every category on and he's using it
to foil to Define what Republican
leadership does to a place right so that
contrast Blue State Red State contrast
is an excellent vehicle by which we
Hammer Republicans for their economic
deliverables which are you know unless
you're in the top three percent of in of
wage earners you have had your wealth
redistributed upwards to the rich and
they have never even bothered to take a
piss on you
so we can we can really tap into that
and people can see that in their
day-to-day so it's not a hard you're not
asking them to drink water for the first
time you're getting that to redirect
their their ire of the economy where it
belongs which is on the Republican party
which has decimated the American middle
class and and taken us from number one
in the world across almost every
category to you know you know basically
uh
We're Men
who wants America to be meh right nobody
do we want to be number [__] one and
we can do it but we've got to get out of
this Reaganomics star of the Beast you
know lie about trickle-down economics
and we need to prosecute Republicans for
for killing um what was by the way the
the strongest middle class you know in
the world coming out of World War II and
out of the you know 50s and 60s when
they got a hold of tax code and they
started giving all of our money to the
rich
you know I've got a personal story about
the Reaganomics and
um tax higher tax brackets and that sort
of thing and red States versus blue
States like you're saying Newsome so
when I was 18 I thought you know what
I'm gonna I'm gonna be a business person
I'm gonna have all kinds of money just
piles of money you know what I mean
Rachel I need an accountant so I went to
the local accountant there that was the
the accountant that you have in the town
that I lived in if you add an accountant
that was the guy so I went to him I sat
down and we were talking and he told me
he said you know in the 1980s I believe
what Ronald Reagan was saying I voted
for him twice I believed in supply-side
economics until I saw what it produced
which was [__] he said supply side
economics is horseshit it's absolute
horseshit I'm an accountant and I'm here
to tell you it's all [__] when you
when you do it from that direction he
said what I can tell you is in this
country in this country if you have a
tax problem if your problem is that you
owe too much in taxes you have a good
problem right now in this country you
are making you are making money if
you're not making money in this country
our progressive tax system at the time
this was years ago at the time did not
they they gave you credits this uh uh
earned income credits child tax credits
Mary credits house credits they give you
credits credits credits because they
want you to do all this stuff but when
you have a tax problem it might be a
good thing so make more money is what
you want to do have that tax problem is
kind of the way he put it to me and
really it started me on this journey of
thinking differently about demand about
supplying about the economy about taxes
and where it goes because I I I agree
with you that Newsome has this great
messaging in red States versus blue
States and the reason why rural white
people have always been able to convince
those real white people who have low low
wages low low uh low taxes they don't
have have a lot of they don't it doesn't
cost a lot of money to live in a trailer
and Rural Missouri it really doesn't
the reason why they've been able to
convince them is oh my God if you moved
to California you would drown yourself
in taxes as opposed to drowning yourself
in poverty like you are here right
they've always been able to use that one
point that one point of taxes to
convince people that it's not the grass
isn't greener on the other side you you
trying to pull yourself up by the
bootstraps here because Republican
policies aren't doing you any good is
the way to go and that's that's always
been their shtick and it's starting to
bleed into culture wars right that's
what they're doing with this stuff
speaking of culture Warriors
how in bonehead of the week Marjorie
Taylor green she ends up you know a lot
of people are like look you guys just
got to take her off this pole you know
this has become like yeah it's not fair
it's hard
the queen of boneheads she did a lot of
bone-headed [__] this week
um which I think is the reason why she's
the winner but I think our audience when
they see her on the poll they're like
[__] we're just gonna make her the
winner so Tony has to figure out a way
to find as many Clips as he can of
Marjorie Taylor green being a bonehead
here's one of them uh I don't know if
you heard about the cocaine in the white
house if you haven't been watching Fox
News you might not have heard but if
you've been watching Fox News you
definitely know that there was cocaine
found in the White House
and like as if drugs don't go in and out
of the White House and they haven't for
years come on people King yeah the
Cheeto dust q and honor had mountains of
Adderall in the White House come on
let's not pretend that there's not drugs
in the white house but here's Marjorie
Taylor green after the secret service
has concluded their investigation of who
had the dime bag of cocaine after they
did DNA testing we wasted our tax money
did you know that Rachel we wasted our
tax money to DNA test this bag of
cocaine it seems ridiculous to me
let's listen to how Marge frames it up
I'm sure it's bone-headed it definitely
is its March
here is American citizens every single
day go through drug tests as part of
their employment for their jobs this is
a common practice uh uh just speaking
with the Secret Service now my question
to them was they were able to narrow
down a list of approximately 500 people
that God left a small bag of cocaine in
a cubby now these are Cubbies that are
controlled by the administration not by
the Secret Service when they enter into
the foyer off the West executive
entrance this this cocaine was found
there so they were able to bring the
list narrow it down to approximately 500
people my question to them was have they
drug tested this list of 500 potential
suspects okay okay I can't take it
anymore it's so stupid so so what she's
saying is that that their secret service
is going to go out and drug test every
single person that walked through this
entrance which again Marjorie Taylor
green either knows this or is a complete
bonehead and doesn't know this that
almost a lot of those people in there
don't work for the federal government
they don't work for the federal
government they're there as visitors
with people who are staff as the federal
government this is really stupid this is
stupid stuff why why are why do we have
to continue to talk about these stupid
things is it because cocaine and Hunter
Biden sound so good in their narrative
is that why that they that we have to
keep talking about this
oh yeah it's it's perfect fodder for
their conspiracies about Hunter right I
mean you can ask for better timing and a
better Scandal so much so that I was
like I wouldn't be surprised if a maggot
put it you know in there so that they
could have a whole Scandal and you know
it's weird to me that there's no DNA or
fingerprints on a bag of cocaine it
seems like you know that that's kind of
interesting to me right uh which is good
news because Tony and unrelated news I
lost a bag of cocaine not long ago
when's the last time when's the last
time you were in DC when's the last time
you're indeed
[Laughter]
on a drug test I've always wanted to
drug test Marge because I'm pretty sure
she's gone male testosterone and I wanna
I wanna [__] know right because you
know that you know she's taking gender
um reassignment hormones in order to
grow those those arms so you know and
she shows them off every time right
maybe she should be lining up for a drug
test
maybe we need to verify that she's even
biologically female who [__] knows
right I mean she could be one of these
like Manchurian candidates right and
they're catching on to it because they
just kicked her out of the freedom
caucus so maybe they kicked her out
because they know that she's actually a
biological male right and they you know
how they hate trans people so that could
that could be that could be you know
that's a good point and I you know I
I've taken two because they like to
misgender people and they think CIS is
they think sis is a slur because they
use trans as a slur even though it's not
so I've taken to Twitter to start
misgendering these especially the dudes
start misgendering them on purpose like
I'll call them sis and girl you know and
it's all intentional you know just to
get under their skin because they like
to do it so why not I'm gonna do it to
them too here's Marge on the floor did
you did you know that Marjorie Taylor
green this week she cares about veterans
when she went to vote for the The Backs
act for healthcare prevention she voted
against that right she did not want
veterans to receive health care she does
not like when veterans receive Health
Care oh well kind of maybe this week
well you know when it serves her
interest then she likes it let's listen
but I would like to talk about the
people that we should care about the
people we should be spending our
American tax dollars for one of them is
a man named Mike Reynolds Mike lives in
my district and Mike is a veteran that
served our country Mike has a brain
injury a brain injury that he sustained
serving the United States of America and
our military
Mike did not get help from because she
voted against him she voted against her
constituent that is why she's such a
bonehead here is because oh [__] dude
and really honestly if Mike gave her
permission to tell the story Mike's more
of a bonehead than she is because Mike
doesn't realize that Marjorie Taylor
green is not her representative Marjorie
Taylor green is is an online influencer
who pretends to represent him when she
actually votes against him she votes
against him and this interest of his
brain injury yes
go expand on that if you can I'm going
to find one more clip oh yeah I mean
it's exactly right I need people to
understand like you know this guy Mike
he doesn't know that Tony because he he
he's in a ecosystem a media ecosystem
that is you know you know lying to them
on purpose right so you know people
think oh well Republicans know all this
[__] they just don't care actually no
they most of them don't know it okay
because if it's not covered on Fox News
like the Dominion lawsuit like the law
is like the election stuff like Trump's
crimes right if it's not covered on
their news then it doesn't happen so
Mike probably has no idea that Marge and
her Maga friends held up veterans Health
Care voted it down uh made vets come in
Camp in DC for days to be able to get
help for the disabilities they incurred
during their service and uh you know
that's just classic par for the course
for her and and here's the thing is
people won't know it unless we find a
way to tell people like Mike the truth
about the Republican party and what it's
doing to them
well and even even her friends in the
Senate were fist bumping when it when it
failed in the Senate the first time
um yeah Jon Stewart had to come back and
and uh to Washington and really get
heated
um in uh on uh on the Capital One on the
capitol steps to get them to realize
that hey hey it's probably a good idea
to support veterans where you've
destroyed their their health care
um and it's probably a good idea to give
them the health care that they've earned
I'm looking for the clip where Marjorie
Taylor green is yeah I mean we should be
telling America the [__] truth about
the Republican party they hate veterans
okay they see veterans just like they
see every [__] buddy else as takers
takers takers that they should short
dime and and
um you know steal and and just make life
as miserable as possible for there's
absolutely no like when you when you
tell me Republicans love veterans right
I can't find any policy proof of that
right all the power
show of veterans getting increased
benefits from the government come from
Democrats with either leading the uh
effort or having to do it completely on
their own and we need to make that
really clear that that Republicans hate
veterans
well um speaking of hating veterans
here's Marge loving Putin hating hating
uh hating the west Western democracy uh
let me give you her Amendment here
amendment number six directs the
president to withdraw the U.S from NATO
my Amendment would direct the president
withdrawal from NATO they are not a
reliable partner whose defense spending
should be paid for by American citizens
for the better part of the last decade
Germany has contributed only around one
percent of its GDP to finance NATO
obligations while the United States is
paying around four percent of our GDP to
defend NATO countries the United States
has been financing and promising to
defend NATO countries for decades and
paying more than its fair share ah Putin
couldn't erode it any better could could
have I I don't know I mean no he
certainly couldn't yeah yeah right yeah
no I mean here's and here's something I
want people to understand about NATO
because Marge clearly doesn't understand
it okay we aren't paying for [__]
percent on NATO because we're nice
people that like to give our money away
to other [__] people all right we're
paying for NATO because it serves our
interests like NATO helps America having
the European countries in an alliance
blocked in to hold our communist and
dictator authoritarian foes at Bay in
China North Korea and Russia is actually
a massively good security investment for
this country that has proven especially
in this last two years with the
expansion and the response to the
Russian illegal invasion of Ukraine by
Russia has proven to be worth every
[__] dollar right that that we've put
into NATO has affirmed that you know for
80 years we've held Global Security yes
there's been Wars guys there's been the
Korean War Vietnam War the Iraq Wars
they're you know war in certain in
Serbia and other places yes I'm not
saying there's no conflict but
geopolitically we've never lived in the
time period more stable than the last 80
years and the reason my friends is
because of our NATO alliance so what
whatever we're paying the return on
investment has been you know given back
a thousand fold and we're not paying
because we care about France and Germany
yes as I'm sure some people do okay and
and I do right in terms of the model but
at the end of the day it's about
American interests that we're supporting
we're not supporting Global interest
unless it supports our interest and and
that's why we're so robustly in charge
of NATO and the you know it's also you
know the reason I like to be king of my
house is that the king that is in charge
of the remote control right like a
person who pays most of the bills gets
to control the remote right and so like
it's not like we don't want
egalitarianism NATO because we want to
have a heavier [__] hand over how
NATO is run in the direction it goes and
the proof is in the [__] pudding
because what did turkey do they caved on
adding Sweden to Nato right and now we
have another NATO country just this week
added into that Alliance that has been
born more fruit for Humanity than any
investment ever in the history of human
civilization and it feels like even even
Joe Biden had to move his goal post uh
on Ukraine joining NATO this week
because when he went into the NATO
Summit he was saying no we're not and
then by the time he met with the
Ukrainian president zielinski he was
much closer to saying yes Ukraine should
be a NATO Ally and they should be
admitted as soon as possible Texas Paul
brings up a good point here he says
we're not paying four percent to Nato
that four percent is our military budget
the entire military budget of our GDP
um which Texas ball that's what we get
for taking facts from Marjorie Taylor
green right well that's the one reason
why I say Putin couldn't have read it
written it better because it's just full
of Russian propaganda right Marjorie
Taylor green is 100 yeah the Republican
party is Russian propaganda they love
that the Republican party is
participating in culture wars and as
they do this culture War thing because
they're the one that's really at war
with culture the left and the American
people already have our culture the
culture has already won yes that's what
people don't understand is culture the
culture War is Over it's already won
they're mad that they lost that's what
they're mad about that's what the locism
and that's why they're doing this and I
actually can't be more excited about
them having their platform being cocaine
Hunter Biden's dick pics and fake
whistleblowers who are Chinese spies for
their platform next year I'm I'm [__]
super excited about that being their
platform because folks they have no no
other answer in sight and that is why
Marjorie Taylor green is the bonehead of
the week and she's the winner of the
bone of the week now I don't have the
proper video but Rachel here's what we
do every week we give the winner their
due with a special little Didion song
and horse race so this is last week's
because Marge won last week and I
actually think she won the week before
so but here it is
we're gonna have to consider that Marge
is no longer on the list but
um she's such it's so easy to put her in
but uh let's let's do this let's give
the petty Yeti let's give three toes
Marjorie trailer green her do
[Music]
[Applause]
oh thank you Dr Rachel bidicoffer for
joining us for bonehead of the week I'm
so glad you came and yes co-hosted I
wish we'd had more time for the
dishonorable mention and the alpha cook
we do some other categories because
here's what we found we like we used to
do the poll early in the week and then
by the time we got to the end of the
week we're like well [__] those three
people those stories are irrelevant like
like those are ancient history
we live in a circus town so right so
here's what we had to do we did the poll
on Thursdays and then we had to add
special categories in case boneheads
popped up on Friday morning so we do
dishonorable mention Albuquerque we
didn't have time this week but Dr Rachel
bittickoffer I'm so glad you joined us
for bone end of the week the audience
loves it I got a few more Clips to show
the audience so don't go anywhere and Dr
Rachel bit of cover my friend thanks for
joining us I appreciate you doing this
I'm so glad it was that was you that
picked the seat here so
um tell us tell us one more time because
I Know You released a tweet the other
day you sent it to me tell us about your
book you got early early on the book
tell us about that real quick
no the book yeah the title the cover is
out now so it's on Amazon for pre-order
and I'm so excited that the book doesn't
come out guys until February of next
year because it takes a very long time
to create a book so you know you can
pre-order it now it's on Amazon hit them
where it hurts how to save America
um uh American democracy by beating the
Republicans at their own game and it is
by me Rachel bidikoffer I'm the only bit
of Coffer on Amazon too so hey it's so
helpful to have like a name that nobody
likes right it means like a thread
handle like you have anything I want
under original that's right I would
never want this name so you can find it
easily if you just Google Amazon
so go to Amazon search beta Coffer
that's
b-i-t-e-c-o-f-e-r bit of Coffer also
follow her on threads and if you're
still on that Nazi dumpster fire Twitter
follow her over there too she's always
going after the right wing over there
giving you the proper way to defeat
Fascism and I think her Twitter account
is the machine maybe the threads account
will be uh also the machine that defeats
fascism Rachel thanks for joining us doc
everybody building it is
we'll talk to you soon my friend
[Music]
[Applause]
do
oh bonehead of the week I'm so excited
that Dr Rachel bittickoffer joined us
for bonehead of the week aren't you I
have a few more Clips Jay don't go
anywhere don't go anywhere I got a few
more Clips I want to show you I only had
DOC for 45 minutes
so I told her from from 12 well my time
but uh Eastern one to 1 45 so she gave
me 45 minutes so that's why we weren't
able to jam in the uh Alpha Cup and the
dishonorable mention I wanted to keep it
simple I wanted to keep respect for her
time but I think it's uh great that
Rachel joined us
um here for uh bonehead of the week and
again I think as if Gabe Sanchez misses
some days or if I miss some days maybe
we'll do a guest host like Gabe was the
host maybe we'll do a guest host yes
co-host I like that that's kind of fun
that's just as fun or better than um
than having having a guest on so go
follow Rachel on threads uh again she's
everyone's billing their account over on
threads but follow her on Twitter too if
you're still on Twitter if you're still
watching the dumpster fire on Twitter
speaking of Twitter dumpster fires let's
go to my um I got a few videos I'm going
to show you here
let's go to my uh
my Twitter uh uh uh thing oh oh yes
speaking of Nazis over on Twitter uh the
Surfs point this out and this tweet here
this is uh and they posted this video of
Nick Fuentes
um remember uh we this week we showed
one of his simps who was flexing in the
mirror who he loved he loved he loved
Nick Fuentes and he loved that he's one
of the white Warriors of Nick Fuentes
here is Nick Fuentes
um in his own words describing how he
feels about the world and his worldview
let's listen here's the pathway we have
one more election where white people can
make the decision but white people got
to make the right decision and then
Trump's got to get in there and never
leave that to me at this point is a
pathway it's time to shut up hang on
hang on this volume is not loud enough
let me see if I can let me see if I can
fix this
oh boy
I I'm trying with the volume sometimes
it just it's not coming through here
let's see if this let's see if this
works let's see if this helps all right
I'm going to try this let's see if it
works here's the path nope we have one
more election where white people can
make the decision the white people got
to make the right decision and then
Trump's got to get in there and never
leave that to me at this point is a
pathway it's time to shut up
elect Trump one more time and then
having elections we have got to talk
about the
of our world view
and what it would look like to build a
society based on our distinct worldview
it looks like a society where women
don't have the right to vote and it
looks like a society where boys and
girls get married as teenagers and start
having kids and they don't use birth
control and they don't use
contraceptives and they have big
families and a high birth rate and it
looks like women wearing veils at church
and it looks like women not being in the
workforce Banning gay marriage is back
on the menu Banning sodomy is back on
the menu Banning contraceptives is back
on the menu
and basically we're having something
like Taliban rule in America in a good
way we're having something like a
Catholic Taliban rule in America okay I
don't support women's rights I don't
support LGBT rights I believe in race
and gender essentialism I'm Catholic I'm
a Catholic reactionary I believe that
organized jewelry is extremely
influential in the United States and
pushes America towards an open Society
liberalism internationalism for their
own benefit we need to go back to
burning women alive more you know these
left-wing people in their heart of
hearts they know they're wrong because
like they know that black people are
violent Hitler was a German Statesman
you know we're not with the Jim Crow
stuff who cares oh yeah to drink out of
a different water fountain big deal
don't tell me they're entitled to their
religion if their religion involves my
Lord in hell then they can get out of
America oh I'm anti-Semitic
yeah I found your town bud you think I'm
anti-semitic you think I care what a
Antichrist believes in the military into
these black neighborhoods there you go
there's the Republican gqp platform for
2024. uh it's spoken like a true [__]
from Nick Fuentes that Nazi I mean it's
pretty simple right you're wondering
like Tony how do you know all this stuff
about what the Republicans are going to
say because I I just listened to what
the [__] Nazis are going to say
before the Republicans said you think
like like Rachel said do you think Eli
crane doesn't speak like that and call
black people colored people you think he
doesn't eat but he totally does that he
says much worse than colored people
folks
he uses the hard R for sure Eli crane
uses the hard arm this week he's used it
probably today already and it's only
it's not even it's not even the evening
time okay
this isn't this isn't [__] rocket
science to understand where these people
are getting this nonsense it's it's
rooted in white supremacy it's rooted in
Neo-Nazi ism
get with it trumpism is American Nazism
okay it's American fascism that's what
it is that's why Nick Fuentes loves
Trump because he gives them permission
to be the worst version of themselves
and the Republicans do as well speaking
of Rachel the chat was asking earlier
someone brought this to my attention a
moderator brought this to my attention
is there going to be an audio book that
was a question people had about Rachel's
because to defeat people like Nick
Fuentes and the politicians who follow
him you're gonna wanna read Rachel's
book
You're Gonna Want to read it it's like a
road map of how to beat fascism
and yes there is going to be an audio
version and it will be read by her I
confirmed it she just she messaged I
messaged her she messaged me back there
will be an audio book and it will be
read by Dr Rachel bidikoffer so I'm
super excited about that not only about
getting the book but getting an
audiobook I when when she sent out her
uh her message her tweet about it let me
let me see if I can find that real quick
um when she sent out her tweet about the
book I asked her I said
um
I said uh
where do we get a signed copy here it is
uh it says uh now available for
pre-order tired of losing elections I'm
excited to announce the pre-order of my
book written by the uh written with the
amazing Aaron Murphy is now open hit him
where it hurts how to save democracy by
beating Republicans at their own game
there's the
there's the cover there there's the
Amazon link and I am going to uh undo
this retweet and redo this Tweety
retweet to bring it at the top
of the timeline so get get your
pre-order available now you're not going
to want them if you buy a book next year
if you buy a book this is the book to
get and if you pre-order it you'll get
it as soon as they are printed and sent
out so this is uh and again I don't know
if you've watched the show for a while
but if you've seen Dr Rachel bittickoff
are on here last year we had her as a
guest and she coined the phrase on this
Show's strategic outrage
we were talking and she she coined the
foreign strategic outrage and we've used
it ever since and um I think I think
it's perfect I'm sure it appeared in the
book a few times and hit him where it
hurts so go pre-order with Dr Rachel
bidikoffer
um here let me let me give you the uh
let's see if I can get that let's see if
I can get the link here I'll put the
link in the in the chat and copy here
I'll give and let's do
are you ready you ready no miss it
here's the here's the Amazon link I got
it in the chat there now so there's the
Amazon Link in all the chats so you can
go
you can go grab the the Kendo version
the audiobook version and the hardcover
from Dr Rachel bittickoffer there on
Amazon it's all there on Amazon here let
me let me see if I can show it to you
here that way you guys can see it why
not we might as well we might as well uh
promote doc right that's what I want to
do
well let's see she ain't paying me to do
this
based okay so here's here's the Amazon
here's the Amazon
um
the listing here so you see there's the
book there's Rachel
and then here's the book hit him where
it hurts save to my say how to say
democracy by beating Republicans at
their own game
hardcover it comes out February 6 2024
and by Dr Rachel bidikoffer and Aaron
Murphy
so you can get the Kindle version the
audiobook or the hardcover
so go get your pre-order now okay let's
see I I think I got one more one more
clip I wanted to show you uh before we
end the day before we end the week boy I
I'm telling you that was
I I like hey okay I like having Gabe
doing bonehead of the week but boy
haven't Dr Rachel bittick offer with
something else oh here's a great one
Steve Cohen a Democrat of Tennessee uh
you want to see how to slap these
fascists down in a meeting or in a
committee meeting here you go now you're
gonna see Jim Jordan here he's the
chairman of this stupid committee
um the stupid chairman of this stupid
committee he's gonna stand up and walk
away as he is he gives time to Cohen
here
um here is
here is uh
and and you're gonna see Daryl Aisha
Daryl Aisha is sitting here you're going
to see Daryl Isa just looking for Jim
Jordan to come back uh to to get
involved because he's the chairman here
but we'll watch this thank you Mr chair
on thank you for being here and for
putting up with some of the questions
you've been asked yesterday FBI director
Ray sat here almost five hours and put
up with continual questions attacking
his patriotism his judgment
uh it was really amazing the hypocrisy
that was shown
the issue was weaponization of the FBI
and yet
every member of this panel who was here
on January 6 2021.
knows
that the government was weaponized on
that day as I said nuclearized to take
over the government to overthrow the
government and contradiction of the oath
of office that each of us had taken and
that we've learned that certain members
of this committee
went and met with Donald Trump
and that they were participating in the
overthrow of our government the
nuclearization slash weaponization of
our government and yet they had the
hoods book The Audacity the lack of
Integrity the question raise judgment
and went on and on and I'm sorry I came
in here today and it's a gentleman
accusing us of a lack of Integrity yeah
yes he is doing whatever it is to shut
up
yeah I'm sure the chairman will rule
when he comes back okay so you notice
there okay let's back it up because I
want I want you to notice when when this
interjects because you you have to draw
a point of order you can't just uh take
someone's time but there is no chairman
okay so let me go all the way back here
you see Jim Jordan got up there see him
see him right here he got up and left as
Cohen was about to speak he's leaving
the room here he's probably going to
find some more fake whistleblowers some
more Chinese spies that he can claim or
whistleblers I'm sure that's what he's
doing he's going to meet with some more
Chinese spies but if we go forward here
um
and and we we watched Cohen round up
here and then uh listen again to Daryl
Isaac as Daryl ice is the one who says
about the chairman he's the one who says
oh I'm sure the chairman will rule when
he comes back because the chairman is
not in the room he's meeting with
Chinese spies I would imagine painting
the overthrow of our government the
nuclearization slash weaponization of
our government and yet they had the
husband the audacity the lack of
Integrity to question raise judgment
and went on and on and I'm sorry I came
in here today and it's a gentleman
accusing us of a lack of Integrity Mr
chairman if you would ask whoever it is
to shut up okay you notice there is no
chairman so when he's speaking to the
chairman the chair is empty there is no
chairman Again Jim Jordan is probably
outside in the hallway meeting with
Chinese spies or Russian spies or who
knows who knows it's probably someone
who's going to be charged with lying to
the FBI about Hunter Biden's prostitute
laptop and big dick pics and gazillions
of dollars uh being funneled through
Hunter Biden's
um ball sack to Joe Biden or some [__] I
know I don't know who knows what the
[__] they'll make up next
um but you notice he calls for the chair
now notice
notice what Daryl Isis leaning in here
to to give Cohen the idea that hey
there's not a chair here that you're
speaking to because the chairman is
derelict in his duty now but let's let's
listen
I'm sure the chairman will rule when he
comes back today and I heard some
questions about your relationship Cohen
doesn't give a [__]
hey
you don't talk about rope and a house
where a man's been hung
you don't ask about membership in the
bar association on a Judiciary Committee
where there are members who never pass
the bar and aren't members of the bar
boom
uh Jim Jordan that too not even a member
of the bar so that's the best part Jim
Jordan gets up to go again I'm just
speculating here I'm sure he's talking
to more Chinese spies convincing them to
go lying to the FBI about Hunter Biden
so that way he can act like he's got a
whistleblower I'm just saying that's
probably what's happening
I I can't confirm or deny that I just
get a sense of Jim Jordan doing that all
the time but
representative Cohen here says hey it
points out that Jim Jordan
Steve Cohen says [__] hadn't
even passed the bar that's fantastic
that was great that was a great clip I
really enjoyed that clip so I want to
show it to you guys of exactly how we
should treat these [__] skin bags
these listen if you think that we're
going to treat unserious people
seriously you you are highly mistaken
and you shouldn't um there's one more
clip I want to show you of a king
Jeffries here
um a moderator sent it to me uh so I
want to show it to you here about
um before we leave we got a few more
minutes here no
um this is the National Defense
authorization act uh and here's his
response to the hyper partisan GOP uh
National Defense Act we have to pass the
National Defense authorization Act
in order to make sure that
our military the greatest military in my
view in the history of the world has
everything that it needs to protect
the Safety and Security of the American
people
and the National Defense authorization
act historically
is a bipartisan legislative effort that
has now been hijacked by extreme Mega
Republicans who want to wage their
so-called culture war against the men
and women of the United States military
I mean you can't make this stuff up
and the only explanation for it
is that they are so obsessed
with jamming their extreme right-wing
ideology down the throats of the
American people
that extreme American Republicans are
willing to even detonate the ability
of our military
to do what it needs to do to keep us
safe we have to pass and there you go
there is the future longest serving
Speaker of the House of Representatives
and it's you that will do that it's you
if you engage in your democracy if you
truly do it not only will we in the
presidency not only will we win Senate
seats we'll put a king Jeffrey as this
at the an actual Speaker of the House an
actual leader an actual leader that's
what we're gonna do that's what we're
going to do and we're going to show that
to you every single weekday here on the
Tony Michaels podcast so don't forget to
subscribe here like it every single time
when you come into the chat and when you
leave the chat make sure you push the
like button
apparently I don't say it enough and the
reason why you need to push the like
button and engage in the video is
because YouTube will push it out more
more people will see it we have more
people to see it more people will watch
we'll have a bigger chat family if you
can imagine having a bigger chat family
also you can watch it on Facebook at the
Tony Michaels like and share it there as
well always share the link there you can
download it every single weekday and you
should download the audio version every
single weekday on Apple Spotify and
Google is very important to get us in
the rankings also it's free to follow us
on Twitch at twitch.tv Tony Michaels and
I want to thank all the people who have
linked their Amazon Prime account to
their Twitch account and re-subscribe
and subscribed with their Amazon gaming
on their Amazon Prime account if you
want to know how to do it
here's how go to the Tony michaels.com
that's the Tony michaels.com it's the
fourth link down our great moderator the
mighty librarian gave you directions on
how to link your Amazon account with
your Twitch account and then give us
that one free subscription that you get
with your Amazon Prime we get like two
dollars and it doesn't cost you a thing
every single month now you got to renew
it and the directions to re-subscribe
are there too and it's really easy takes
like two seconds also why you're on the
Tony michaels.com check out a few things
check out patreon this weekend I think
I'm gonna do an ask me anything sometime
when you ask me anything and and a rant
we'll just we'll combine them both I'll
do it something this weekend on patreon
I'm not going to take the weekend off
we're going to do something some point
so if you're on patreon listen up we're
gonna do something this weekend check
out to make sure you pay attention to
those links if you're not live it's okay
you can re-watch it there over on
patreon so go to the Tony michaels.com
you can click the patreon link and find
out what the weekend chat's about we
need more people over there on patreon
we need to get some more [__] bam
over there and only it starts at five
bucks and it goes up from there but any
support is good support and we love your
support there on patreon.com the Tony
Michaels also check out the merch store
you're not going to want to miss the
[__] merch with the [__] fanny
pack Everyone likes that fanny pack
and fanny pack people have been buying
the rainbow [__] them stickers as well
the pride stickers also check out the
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you can get
you a grande Santos can go [__] himself
sure too also let them eat rake merch is
over there on the store she'll go to the
Tony michaels.com that's the
tonymichaels.com click the merch store
or you can go to
store.thetonymichaels.com that's some of
my Shameless plugs
I appreciate you guys having you here I
am so excited that we had a guest
co-host for bone end of the week I can't
wait till Gabe's back I think he's back
on Monday so don't don't miss Monday
Gabe Sanchez
that guy with the last name
Sanchez will be here on Monday don't
miss it same time same place have a
great weekend Surf's Up [__]
you've been listening to the Tony
Michaels podcast in your face commentary
of current events and political news no
rules No Boundaries I think we've made
that perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed
the show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[__] them [__] em
[Music]
Murphy's mealborn headass Beacon